hello everyone and welcome back to the
Prague chess festival the Masters
edition it's all it is a few verses
spent all our additional it's a game
from round three in in round two all of
the games were drawn so I decided not to
show any games from from round two but
we are going to show at least at least
two from round three
so this is the first one I decided to
show let's see how it goes
both of them are players over 2700 Plus
caliber so a very very strong
competition without further ado let's
check it out and also I would just like
to say that the pairings for round one
of the 2020 candidates tournament have
been published but we're gonna discuss
that for a bit after we check out the
game so ali reza with the white pieces
opens with E for weave e5 Knight f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
reuleaux PES is on the board with a 6
more fees defense and the bishop back to
a4 now we have Knight f6 castles Bishop
to e7 and d3 so the the closed rule opus
we have b5 pushing the best back Bishop
b3 and d6 so fairly standard stuff c3
making room for the bishop and c2 as the
knight will definitely attack it to make
room for the c5 pawn with castles and
the white goes h3 takes away the g4
Square from blacks pieces and now the
standard maneuver Knights to a5
attacking the bishop also preparing to
advance with the C pawn bishop back to C
- of course keeping the bishop Aaron and
c5 now and while there are a few moves
that are popular here a fallujah decides
for d4 immediately strikes in the center
Queen to c7 developing the Queen and now
fallujah decides to close the center
with d5 and here the position has been
reached a few times c4 is the most
popular option here but here in this
game we have Knight to c4 bye-bye heart
accretion and it's not a new move it's
been played once
so basically calling White's to play b3
you cannot develop your bishop otherwise
you would lose your B to pawn so b3
night sorry Knight back to b6 and now
there is one game from 2003
even village vs. parish
we're Knights the h-2a night HD was
played and black was able to win the
game why decided to make room for the
for this f4 thrust but here we have a
four by future and it is as of move 14
that we have a completely new game so
what what's happening here let's see
first we have if you for example capture
let's say captures captures now you do
have to develop your Bishop somehow
probably to a six so you can push a five
but now that Knights the a3 the knight
gets this very nice be five square to be
his outpost and if Bishop de six six
nine b5 you could capture characters
captures and now black has a past
a pawn White has a past be pawn but why
the b-pawn is a bit more far far
advanced and you have a very firm grip
on the a4 square so probably white white
is to be preferred here and of course if
you don't gain anything but capturing
you should a general rule is you
shouldn't capture so c4 now putting
pressure on the b3 pawn and here future
decides to trade everything a captures
with captures captures on a eight
captures and now captures and c4 with be
captures and c4 and now Bishop to a3
putting pressure on the d6 pawn as it is
a weak point you might consider
attacking it with something like well if
the bishop is developed here you could
go a knight is try to f5 to put pressure
on the pawn this way but also if if
black isn't careful it's a black moves
the Queen somewhere also there are ideas
like Knight captures an 85 because if
you captured in the Bishop hangs on e7
and so on
so a lot of opportunities for whites the
at least grab a pawn so tonight's the d7
now defending the pawn this way now
characterís will only be met with
captures with the Knight Bishop to b4
now strengthening the c3 pawn also
freeing up the a file as a white intense
to use it with Knights to c5 now puts
pressure on the e4 pawn and Queen e2
defends it while also now attacking the
c4 pawn so you have to defend the c4
pawn with nights the b6 by a Hari
Krishna and Knight B to d2 now adding a
second attacker to the c4 pawn and now
harikrishna could decide to move the
knight back Knight cd7 now the Queen
the night guard the c4 pawn but it's a
very passive position for black you
can't really move anything be you're
pretty much stuck guarding the c4 pawn
so hide occasional finds a more active
approach he plays f5 and it's something
that you definitely want to do since you
already have a look on a fate you put
pressure on the e4 pawn so now if white
goes after the c4 point you no longer
have control of the ep.4 pawn so what do
you do here now there is a line you
could actually win a pawn here with
Bishop to a5 you just attack one of the
defenders of the c4 pawn so it's
basically forced and you don't want to
have something like Knight captures here
to add more pressure to the night so
let's say the Queen moves you forcefully
win a pawn but should capture screen
captures and now you go after the pawn
queen a6 pins the knight now you cannot
move it the Queen is undefended here and
now you have to play something let's say
you decide to capture as you want to
keep your extra pawn the shop captures
captures captures and we get to this
position which is something always of
course can considered but it's hard to
decide whether you will be able to and
make use of your extra pawn due to this
very unpleasant pin here and well you
might even attack it with something like
this and it's it's hard to say
it is a pawn definitely a Larissa
decides against it he goes rook to d1
well adding more coverage to the d3
Square but also if the if pawns are
exchanged here then the rook will also
be defending the d5 pawn which is very
important so g6 now just strengthening
the the structure here in the Queen to
e3 now putting more pressure on the c5
Knight here and maybe considering of
well going over to the King side maybe
maybe something like this but it's hard
to say
basically he doesn't want to allow
anything like that so f4 pushes the
Queen back quinta e2 again returning the
Queen pressure to c4 pawn and now Bishop
the a6 adds yet another defender here
but now Alireza
says okay now it's time to remove over
my pieces over to the a file so rook the
a1 already with the threat of just
Bishop captures and c5 you remove the
defender of the bishop on e6 and you
just win a piece so rook to e8 you have
to defend it
and now queen f1 queen f1 with the idea
you want to make a nice doubling of the
queen and rook with rook a5 and bringing
the Queen over to a1 so Queen to c8
already adding another defender to the
bishop and now rook the a5 continuing
with the plan also now if you if you
capture the knight here from character
sorry if you capture capture then you
already get a nice pass deep on salt
knight retreats Knight C to d7 but also
there was a very interesting Knight to
b3 move here point being that you force
the rook back which is very important as
all it as I decided that this is a good
role cliff so if if not b3 you force the
rook back because if you capture let's
say Bishop captures you capture white it
doesn't have time to recapture because
of well you hang the Queen so you have
to move the Queen and now again Knight
see for you again forces the rook to
move back while you threaten to exchange
some more pieces and basically if white
characters then you capture back you
different you nicely have a passport on
b3 that's already defended you you can
exchange here some of the problem black
will have a very very good game so nice
to be three definitely worth considering
Hari Krishna instead goes Knight back to
cease CD 7 so is this one of those cases
where the strongest move is a move with
the knight back well we will just have
to wait and see so Queen - a1 future
continues with its plan he doubles up on
the a file the bishop is now under a lot
of pressure and Bishop to b5 now
offering some trades along the a file
and night to b1 a very important move
otherwise also goes by that the
strongest move is with the knight back
the knight coming to a3 will put a lot
of pressure on the bishop on b5 the
Dutchman b5 is undefended and with the
pawn being pushed to d5 the the c6
square is not available to the bishop so
here you could try a lot of things
although it's it's hard to decide on the
move probably exchanging rooks and Queen
to a6 offering the Queen trade is the
way to go for Hari Krishna but instead
he plays g5 he he you know his spidey
sense doesn't tingle here and what would
you play here so I feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out you know
a nice way out of this mess
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations and finding such a nice
way out of this mess and for those of
you who just want to enjoy a show here
it's well you force the you force
matters and you win some material rook
captures any eight now if Queen captures
then it it's a force line Queen captures
Knight captures and Knight the a3 the
move we mentioned now the bishop is
under a lot of pressure you cannot move
it here so - up to a six and now Knight
the D - you add another attacker to the
c4 pawn and after it's defended Knight a
b6 now you go Bishop here and after
Bishop to e2 you will win this pawn
there's there's no arguing that so
that's one of the options if after rook
captures you go Queen captures so here
of course Hari Krishna decided to go
Knight character Sonny eight but it's
well it's not that different here Queen
to a seven by future you could also
probably go for the for the same idea
you could go night a3 bring this Knight
over here bring the Bishop to e2 and
pile up on the e to point but fallujah
is is much better standing on time so he
gives Hari Krishna something to consider
so now a lot of things are happening
here you cannot move the knight the
bishop hangs so it's not easy to move
pieces here and these two bishops are
definitely coming into play tonight is
coming to a three so it's gonna be very
very hard to move for black so nice the
c7 already adding another defender to
the bishop here but Knight to a3 now
with Bishop to e6 now the knight nicely
guards it but again feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
move for future here while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding
pretty much the only move that actually
wins and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's a bishop to a
four Bishop to a four already you're
threatening really a lot of things
basically you're threatening to bring
the black queen here
which is not gonna be possible to
survive for example if you play h6 let's
say you play
then this is just winning captures
captures and Bishop to a5 now you're
either gonna lose the night since
there's a double attack you cannot move
the knight because you lose the Queen
and if you do something weird like let's
say Bishop to d8 that there's nothing to
do here you either lose the night or
even if you play something like here
then it's again you just remove the
defender of the Bishop and Queen
captures on a6 wins apiece so that's not
really possible and here well Knights
the f6 is what Hari Krishna played here
if you go Knight the f8 the seemingly
guard the g5 born still with the bishop
then White has a tactic Knight captures
on e5 that was in the position all along
now since since the beginning as the
bishop on e7 is unguarded and here in
black will just fall apart - there's
there's no playing this so after Bishop
day for Hydra creation I tried Knight to
f6 again an active move going for the e4
pawn and fallujah says ok let's let's
straight here Knight capture sin g5 and
now again it's hard to decide what to do
here you you lost the pawn here so you
kinda do have to go after one of the
central pawns but again it's hard to
decide what to do here you could go for
some like Queen b7 but still doesn't
really do anything captures captures and
then Knight captures and c4 you just
keep losing more material and if h6
thing ok if the knight moves I'm gonna
win back some material it's not a
problem because you you even lose d6 and
after captures captures you cannot
capture because of captures so after
this Knight to g5 move high recreational
goes Knight f captures and d5 ok he wins
wins the pawn back and also opens up a
discovery to the night he captures on d5
by Fallujah Bishop captures on g5 and
now Bishop captures on d6 so eliminating
this base of the pawn chain is now gonna
be very hard for black to survive Knight
captures on d5 but now Bishop to d7
bringing this Bishop over to e6 with
check and again Fallujah well fully
mobilizes his Bishop air from hell it
seems like every game Fallujah is really
dominating with with his bishop pair so
Queen to b7
now offers a queen trade now but nnd yes
if you trade it's definitely you will
lose this pawn but it's not it's still
game yah you're down one pawn both
players still have the bishop pair maybe
maybe black can save this however I feel
ja not interested after this Queen to b7
an offer of a queen trade he goes Bishop
to e6 check forcing the King to this
dark square diagonal so he can pick up
the e5 pawn with check we have King to
g7 captures with Czech Bishop f6
blocking and now just Queen to d4 and it
was in this position that pantalla
harikrishna resigned the game and an
excellent victory for other as a fuchsia
in round 3 of the Prague chess festival
masters division so here you resign
because you either lose the night if you
move the knight you no longer defend
your bishop so you will lose the bishop
and of course if you trade captures
captures then this comes with check and
after the King moves you will then pick
up the knife so either way your euro was
ending up upper piece so after this room
before hari krishna resigned and like i
said a beautiful win for future against
a very strong 2700 plus player now i
said i'm gonna show at least one more
game from round 3 s there were a lot of
decisive games and a lot of interesting
games so we're gonna check out the
standings tomorrow morning probably when
i post it but i said that we are going
to show the pairings for round 1 of the
candidates tournament 2020 so here it is
hope you're ready for it is it going to
be a while round 1 so in round 1 of the
2020 candidates tournament we have Tim
or a job of versus Fabiano caruana so
very nice very nice and even though
Korea Quran is definitely one of the
favourites to even win the candidates I
don't think I don't think it's going to
be an easy game because our job will
show that that although he's been away
from chess for a long time that he can
still you know play a play with the best
then we have dinkler and vs. 1 cow a
nice Chinese clash then uh nigiri versus
Jana pony she and Alexander green versus
kiddo Alex saying the wild card of the
2020 candidates tournament so it's gonna
be really awesome
it starts in about one month one month
and one day I believe so
you know just want to share that with
you maybe you didn't even know who was
in the candidates maybe you forgot so
hope that helped but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Michael massamilla Luis
Fernandez Vallejo Olin Rambo Allan Poe
Clair and Daniel Vasquez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
proctors festival checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and I will assume
a very soon resume with the Paul Morphy
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and heaviness have an excellent
rest of your weekend